[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
[Music]
happy
hump day
it's wednesday
noon eastern 11 central you know what
time that is it is time for the tony
michaels podcast
every single weekday here on youtube
twitter twitch
and now
on facebook on the midas touch facebook
page we broadcast live all those places
noon eastern 11 central every single
weekday monday through friday we do not
miss a day
live real live
broadcasting
you know we go through the tweety tweets
the trendy trends we have some
interviews
if you guys are new viewers
go over you can also download it after
we're done of course you can't download
it till after we're done because it's
live
so once we go live
i then put it up on all the directories
even even the boycotted ones the most
famously boycotted spotify apple google
all your directories
just go to thetonymichaels.com
you will find all the links there for
the podcast whether you want to watch
the podcast or you just want to listen
to the podcast you can find all the
links there we appreciate everyone
liking sharing
and commenting we have a boy
lisa is here hello lisa
debbie is here
kevin is here kathy is here
uh jacqueline
from facebook is here forrest
uh from facebook is here uh at least
lisa thank you very much for the
for the super sticker there we really
appreciate that again if you guys are
chatting on youtube you can participate
in the super chat or the super sticker
so thank you very much and we have um
let's see we have daryl here
uh
dan is here david from facebook is here
yoda's back good morning [ __ ] fam he
says christina is here
vicky is here from facebook
uh we we just have so many new faces mj
is here good morning good morning mj uh
kevin from toronto
we're all here holy moly we got so many
new listeners we really appreciate all
the new listeners out there on facebook
keep tuning in every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central
um
we we even have some on twitch hello
infits
and we have viewers on twitch as well
go follow all the channels like
subscribe
to the to the youtube channel if you can
that would help us out a lot
if you could do that today's hump day
there's a lot of stuff in the news today
and we still had the third day the third
round
of judge brown jackson making these
white wrinkly republican ball sacks look
like morons
stuffing them in the trash
and we have other democratic senators
stuffing republican senators in the
trash i don't know if you've seen that
senator hirono from hawaii
but she absolutely
she balled up josh hawley like a booger
and flicked him across the room that's
what she did
i said she dunked him in the [ __ ]
trash which she did
she did but she really
squeezed him up like a like a really wet
dr really wet boogers balled him up and
then flicked him across the room
[ __ ] that guy josh holly is absolutely
obsessed with porn as you know
absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with porn
like he can't stop talking about porn
and it's really weird
and and here lately
he can't stop talking about child porn
like he can't stop he can't help himself
it's really weird for someone to just be
blurting out about porn
isn't it
i mean you know when you have
discussions about porn in context of
course right and even child porn when
you're having discussions in context
like we are now we're having to talk
about these things because josh hawley
just can't stop blurting it out
jesus christ what's wrong with this guy
i mean it's it's almost like
it's almost like if you're in a
restaurant right and josh holly's across
the room and you're trying to enjoy
dinner and he goes to order and the
waitress is like
what would you like to eat mr holly and
he's like child porn child porn child
porn and everyone in the restaurant was
like what in the [ __ ] why is he talking
why is he shouting child porn now the
whole entire room is having discussions
about child porn because this guy can't
stop blurting it out
like he can't help himself
most people don't run around in public
blurting out porn
porn porn porn porn bad child porn
soft on child porn like what why are you
obsessed
you're obsessed with it we may have
found a video
on the interwebs we'll play it uh maybe
at the bottom of the hour when gabe
joins us gabe gabe may have found this
video of josh hawley calling into
the laptop repair shop or our tech
support i said yesterday that josh
hawley is so obsessed with child porn
maybe we should search the repair shops
for his laptop i don't know
i don't know maybe
i mean it makes sense right
and it kind of makes sense
josh ollie
[ __ ] rube
what a rube
that guy is
so we have that we have lindsey graham
yesterday making a complete fool out of
himself we we we drug uh
lady g through the mud yesterday here on
the show we'll probably do it again
today
um we also big news today big news
donald trump is not loyal at all
oh big [ __ ] news he dumped mo brooks
oh my god moe brooks had one slight
against donald trump and donald trump
drops his endorsement of mo brooks
who could have ever guessed
that donald trump
at a drop of a hat would turn on
somebody oh no one could have seen that
coming get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
mo brooks doesn't participate for one
moment in the soft coup
in the next cheeto dust kangaroo coup
where they're trying to take the house
and the senate
and he says ah well you know um
maybe just maybe we should stop talking
about the 2020 intellect and then the
former guy
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopypants just loses his [ __ ] mind
and drops his endorsement of mo brooks
which is totally gonna [ __ ] torch
the race in alabama now
it's gonna confuse everyone like whoa
wait a second who are we supposed to
pick because mo brooks
think about it mo brooks is the guy who
was so prepared on january 6 for the
cheeto dust kangaroo goo
that he wore a [ __ ] bulletproof vest
he did he [ __ ] wore a bulletproof
vest on january 6th that's how prepared
mo brooks was for a cheeto dust kangaroo
coup
he was terrified of something you don't
just wear a bulletproof vest you know
just out of nowhere i mean
not as a congressman
what the [ __ ] you had to know something
was gonna happen
he was that committed
he was that committed and he said
something about taking names and kicking
ass on stage as they were trying to rile
up the
the insurrectionist the traitors
that the trove of traitors that trump
had brought to washington
we know now that there was coordinated
efforts in the conspiracy to overturn
the government of the united states
uh in several court documents and
indictments we see that groups like the
oath keepers were in a seditious
conspiracy
and we now see that proud boys were in a
seditious conspiracy it looks like it
spans way past those groups
and the tentacles reach out to roger
stone and into the trump administration
at this point
jesus [ __ ] christ course we knew all
this we knew this we knew this it's just
a matter of the court and the grand
juries putting their facts together
and making sure that the indictments
stick and they can get convictions for
these treasonous seditious pieces of
[ __ ]
which they are getting uh convictions we
have one guilty plea with the oath
keepers and seditious conspiracy
to overturn the constitution of the
united states meet
it's happening
you know a lot of people want this
process to move faster and faster to get
to the top faster and faster and i'm all
for the people at the top in the trump
administration and even trump himself to
pay the price for the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt
because i believe that's what it was is
a cheeto dust coup attempt
they tried to overturn the constitution
of the united states they wanted to
they were treasonous to their oath
and it's not just it's not just trump
there's a lot of them
there's a whole hell of a lot of them
that are treasonous to their oath
yes i said treason
well what do you think one step above
sedition is and they already have the
indictment of conspiracy to commit
sedition you don't think there's going
to be charges of treason somewhere
yeah yeah yeah i get i get the whole
notion that ah the doj and merrick
garland soft all that [ __ ]
you're not gonna hear that on this show
you're not gonna hear that
listen if doj is so goddamn soft why do
they keep reaching their tentacles
further and further into a conspiracy
when federal prosecutors put together a
a conspiracy charge
regardless
of how many people are charged in the
beginning they keep piling on with
superseding indictments
that is how it works that's the whole
point of the word conspiracy and the
government uses that word to its
advantage
100 every single time
that's why they're charged with
conspiracy to commit sedition not actual
sedition
itself because they want far-reaching
tentacles into other groups
and other members of the conspiracy
regardless if that is in the oath
keepers the proud boys the
administration the roger stone uh steve
bannon himself
it will reach
further and further and further and it's
going to and and the other reassurance
that you can have
that that the department of justice is
doing their job i believe is that we
didn't hear a goddamn word about the
indictment and the arrest of enrique
tario until it happened
i mean they even have the nip the nip
video
where he's got his nipples out when
they're arresting him i'm just saying
you know i like the word nipples and i
like to say the word nipples here on the
show and i appreciate and enrique tario
decided that he would
that he wouldn't get dressed when he was
arrested so that way we had the nip
video that way i can say nipples on on
the on the podcast here
um
uh the gabe gave enrique tario a good
handle uh loose lips
what was it loose lips tight nips no no
loose lips hard nips that's what it was
loose lips hard nips is uh enrique
tario's nickname
[Laughter]
you guys can go watch that that
interview
with dakota adams um of course dakota
adams doesn't know enrique tario but he
does he is the estranged son of stuart
rhodes the oath keeper founder
um so
it's uh it's a um
you can go watch the interview and we
asked him about uh not just enrique
tario but the the proud boys in general
and he also gives his opinion on
um
oh the original founder gavin whatever
the hell his name is the the dildo guy i
know there's another opportunity for me
to say a really a really good buzzword
dildo uh but yes the proud boys have the
you know dildo history with their
founders so go go watch that interview
on
on the tubes of you it's there
um so subscribe to the youtube channel
you can go
watch those interviews with dakota adams
we've done three of them we've done
three of them the very first one was
with his mom tasha who is the estranged
wife uh soon to be ex-wife of stuart
rhodes uh they tell us the story about
how stuart got the eye patch so go watch
that one then there's two other
interviews with dakota where he comes on
and gives his commentary of uh ongoing
news of the oath keepers and stuart
rhodes
but this last one he does mention
we do mention the the nip and dildo
story so go go check that out you
definitely don't want to miss those
stories on the podcast if you if you
want to get caught up
hopefully we'll have there there's more
and more oath keeper and browboy news uh
generating over the next few weeks maybe
we'll have dakota back on to give his
commentary dakota adams the estranged
son of stuart actually has a
really brilliant mind and the the thing
is he has a lot of experience with the
mentality of these militias that's why i
love to have him on
because he can speak to the mentality of
these people that like no one else can
because he was right there with stewart
like he was the teenage protege right of
stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers so it's very interesting his
perspective on things and he knows a lot
of stuff about like the bunny ranch and
things that others don't so
so
so
um
oh don don and don's on facebook he
doesn't like that i'm saying nips and
dildos sorry don that's just the kind of
show we do that's kind of the show we do
here is we do the announcements in the
beginning and then we get to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends so if
you're new to the show here on facebook
here's what we do we do the
announcements in the first half 15 20
minutes and then we get to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends so we go
over to twitter and we serve twitter we
we look at all the clips the videos the
stuff that's trending all the trending
all the news and we break it down with
the [ __ ] style
[ __ ] style
commentary
so i i really um appreciate that uh
don um oh he says great comedy show
yeah we we love we love to laugh here we
think that politics and laughter
go hand in hand if you've been watching
the
katanji brown jackson hearings the judge
brown jackson hearings
that uh that that have been going on
there's a lot of comedy in this thing i
mean to watch these republicans really
try their hardest their damnedest
to try to i mean they want to ask they
want to ask judge brown jackson if she's
ever committed sexual assault but they
can't right they can't
i mean
democrats had to ask brett kavanaugh
that over and over and over again and
rehash this and rehash this and rehash
this he cried about loving beer and and
all kinds of [ __ ]
that's because brett kavanaugh's a [ __ ]
bag he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] bag so they had
to ask him about being a [ __ ] bag
judge brown jackson is not so it's
really hard for them to construct
questions
in a way
to make her look that way when she's not
at all
that's the difference and i was talking
about this yesterday everyone says that
the parties are the same bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] the parties are not the same
there are complete differences between
between the republican party and the
democratic party and there's no better
example than right now than these
hearings that we're having for the
confirmation of the of the supreme court
nominee katangi brown jackson there's no
better example of why the parties are
different
just in the actual pick of the justice
who is the nominee for the supreme court
democrats joe biden barack obama whoever
it is picks decent
human beings
decent human beings one and i mean
that's a low [ __ ] bar isn't it for
supreme court justice jesus christ we
should have a lot higher bar than just a
decent [ __ ] human being
i mean it should be a lot higher like
experience work ethic
empathy like all kinds of things
a view of american history and the
american ideal the constitution for
[ __ ] sake
that it is actually a living document
chuck grassley
yeah
we sh it's it's really a stark
difference when you look at just the
questions that can be asked
of a nominee
when you look at the difference between
brown jackson and kavanagh
and you look at the difference between
brown jackson and barrett
you can see the difference in the
parties one party is pro-democracy one
party is pro-america one party wants to
advance this country make it better make
it look more progressive
make the court look like the country and
act like it too
not [ __ ] hide behind their [ __ ] box
ways
like brett kavanaugh did
oh
i like beer and i can't believe you're
accusing me a white man of doing
despicable things even though those
allegations are credible
and then amy coney barrett
hiding behind her religious dogma to
hide her bigotry they do this all the
time lindsey graham tried to unpack this
yesterday and did a horrible job at it
horrible [ __ ] job even asked even
asked judge brown jackson what her
religion was
he did such a horrible job of unpacking
why he's so pissed off
that the left gets to ask a bigot like
amy coney barrett why are you hiding
your bigotry behind your religious dogma
i i assume that
katanji brown jackson is probably just
as faithful as amy coney barrett i
assume
i assume she's a decent human being she
seems to have empathy most people like
that would have faith
but katanji brown jackson has never
never ever ever ever ever ever
hid her bigotry behind her religious
dogma and then veiled it with religion
never has she done that that's why you
can't ask her that
you cannot ask her that because of that
that's why
and that is the stark difference so when
you hear some dumb [ __ ] out
there say that the republicans and the
democrats are exactly the same here's
your example
here's a i mean there's there's
thousands of them and i don't just mean
like a thousand i mean like a thousand
every single [ __ ] day
every single day we pile these things up
but the problem is there's so much
fascism in our country now and there's
so much embracing of fascism at the g
with the gqp and republicans
that it's hard to keep [ __ ] track
but here is a good example of what you
could show someone
of how
how the democrats and the republicans
are two different [ __ ] parties and
they have two different [ __ ] values
this is how
midaskins sent the super sticker thank
you very much midas ken again a reminder
if you go to the youtube chat
you can do a super chat or super sticker
thank you very much anyone who supports
the show not just with super stickers
and super chats likes comments shares
subscribes
we we love you guys here
and we love when you guys come to the
live show in live chat
love
it even if even if you don't totally
agree with me we have some hate watchers
here
we have some hate watchers here is dan
here
and what about chris
is chris here chris in
we got some hate watchers here everyone
knows we have hate why i like the hate
watchers maybe we'll turn them
maybe we'll turn them
the more they listen to to uh uh actual
rhetoric with truth most most of these
people believe uh rhetoric rather it's
true or not so maybe we'll get some some
truth rhetoric and they'll
they'll uh
they'll start to they'll start to hear
some [ __ ] that they never heard before
in a way they've never heard it
a lot of people say that about this show
that we say things that people like me
who look like me don't say
and should say more that's what we tried
to do here
so let's go we got a lot of trending
topics today
um
i think whoopi goldberg is um it gave
another
uh opinion about lindsey graham on the
view that we're gonna get to
uh let's see we have
oh yes the the main story though is uh
tom trump dumps mo brooks i'm sure we'll
get to more clips of the the
confirmation hearing
of uh judge brown jackson home depot's
in the news for white privilege tom
tillis is a [ __ ] uh so we'll get to
that and also the aca turns 12 today i
believe that's the age of it is 12. it's
12th birthday
we'll sing happy birthday to the aca i'm
just kidding we're not going to sing
happy birthday uh uh senator ossoff's in
the news the taliban is in the news
apparently they're getting more and more
progressive even the taliban might be
more progressive than the republican
party imagine that manafort gets stopped
in an airport yeah and of course true
social sucks so we will um
we will break down
all those um
trends well we'll try to get the most of
them
we will try to get most of them but the
the one thing i want to say when you are
attempting a soft coup
mo brooks mo problems let's start the
countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we are reach the
shitlist roundup section of the show
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends of the day
let's see uh we we get them
we get and let's start with the timeline
we got a few things out i want to show
you a few things before we get to the
tweety tweets and attorney trends of
course you know what
happens is i get in a rabbit hole on my
timeline of [ __ ] that i've retweeted and
then and then we we don't we don't have
time for the for the for the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends let's make
this a little bigger so y'alls can see
it
y'alls can see it
um you guys you guys seen that charlie
kirk got kicked off of twitter yesterday
right
did you see that
[Laughter]
ah charlie quirky piece of [ __ ] um this
[ __ ] guy rachel bitkoffer you guys
know rachel bitcoffer the political
strategist from strike back she's the
election whisperer
from the 2018 midterms um she's working
hard to try to make sure these midterms
swing the right way and and the way of
pro-democracy but she went on charlie
kirk's debate night and handed him his
ass
uh here's a little clip of of
rachel making a total fool
out of him let's uh let's listen in to
uh how rachel slam ducks charlie kirk if
i can prove to you the vaccine
mattered and cut death rates big time
and vaccinations guess what we get the
vaccine absolutely not what's your
favorite flower my fa i don't really
think about that
okay well i need to know when i have to
send it to you in the icu buddy
i may we may have doctored that clip
just a bit i'm just just a bit we may
have doctored that i don't know i don't
know mayo mayo says uh
i think mayo's here on twitch
she says no more brooks
no mo brooks
[Laughter]
mail with as few letters as possible
causes as much trouble as possible
on on on twitter there's mayo hey mayo
she's laughing
she's laughing
[Laughter]
mayo is with us mayo is with us no mo
brooks as few letters
is possible
as few little as possible mayo says i
love her yeah we love mayo too mayo
[Laughter]
we love mayo too one of our favorites
here on the tony michaels podcast
he says good morning to everyone except
marsha blackmail's sheep
did you guys see
did you guys see marsha blackburn's
little diatribe this
i called her the c word i i got i got a
dm saying hey you better be careful with
the c word i was like yeah well it's
marcia blackburn really do i really need
to be careful calling her a [ __ ] i mean
really like if if you're gonna save that
word if you're going to save that word
for a specific person it's going to be
marshall blackburn i mean there's a few
others
out there that you could you know save
that word for and not a lot of people
like yeah i don't like that word but
i don't like that word but is how that
how that sentence starts when you're
talking about marsha blackburn
yeah that word perfectly describes her
but this actually is not a bad depiction
of her hair that she had going on
yesterday during the uh the hearing
where she was questioning uh judge brown
jackson
just saying
thank you hoodlum for your
for your um
for your google search of
uh hairstyles from marsha blackburn okay
oh here here uh gabe gabe found another
picture from yesterday uh he says i
don't understand why everyone's saying
marsha blackburn is inconsiderate she's
literally caring for birds nesting in
her hair if you look really close here
if you look really close it almost looks
like she she is
nesting
um some birds in her hair
and it doesn't even look photoshopped at
all
unfortunately he also
gabe also says blackburn is charging the
bird's rent though so don't don't get
don't get too excited don't get too
excited she is charging them rent
um for the the bird's nest
of a hair that she has
and let's see it do let's go back to the
timeline
okay
um
oh here we go here's some more marshall
blackburn burns marsha blackburn burns i
don't know uh kate says who else doesn't
give a flying [ __ ] about marsha
blackburn's personal opinion on roe v
wade yeah don't give a [ __ ]
i couldn't give two [ __ ] not one [ __ ]
no [ __ ]
not a flying [ __ ] for that matter
about what her her [ __ ] personal
opinion is on roe v wade
don't give a [ __ ]
fact of the matter is is women should
have liberty in this country yeah
there's you [ __ ] there's your
constitutional opinion
marsha blackburn you dumb [ __ ]
is
you should have liberty that's a good
one um
bad company uh retweeted me here i said
marsha blackburn i had a screenshot here
the liberal media will not silence me i
said we [ __ ] know
we know we know you're not gonna shut up
we understand that you're gonna keep
talking say stupid [ __ ] like we get it
and really honestly we should let her
say stupid [ __ ] the more these people
say stupid [ __ ] because i'm going to
show you a senator from indiana that
said some dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] yesterday
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
some ridiculous ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of trash mike braun and
we're i'm going to show it to you we're
going to watch the video you know we
don't look away here we listen to every
single word these stupid idiots say now
bad said what liberal media is she
referring to because most i've seen
leans right some further than others
that's right
the mainstream media isn't left-wing
morons
marsha blackburn
here it is here it is here's the video
we're already there um i tweeted this
video of mike braun brun braun i don't
know who gives a [ __ ] just got removed
from tick tock for bullying i posted
this video on tick tock on my tick tock
account
and it got pulled down for bullying
saying i was bullying him i didn't say
anything in the [ __ ] video
i just played the video of him saying
that [ __ ] racist ass [ __ ] he was
saying i didn't [ __ ] say anything
jesus christ i said i wouldn't [ __ ] you
because i figured people like ah you're
just lying tony it didn't actually get
deleted because of bullying no i'm
telling you that's what it did i
wouldn't [ __ ] you you're my favorite
turd you guys are my favorite turds by
the way you really are um
i said this is what they mean when they
say make america great again
this is what they mean they don't mean
these bastards aren't talking about good
jobs the economy gas prices they're not
talking about that [ __ ]
and anyone who believes that make
america great again is about jobs or the
economy or gas prices is a dumb
[ __ ]
you are a dumb [ __ ] if you think
that's what they're talking about
so you're out there and you're like oh
yeah well it's all about it's all about
it's all about uh
making sure that we have good jobs and a
good economy
and blah blah blah blah [ __ ] blind no
no it's not
it's this this is what they mean by make
america great again
when they say [ __ ] like states rights
the civil war was about states rights
yeah states rights to own slaves
what don't you [ __ ] understand
i'm gonna show you a tweet by walter
masterson that bundles that up in a
beautiful little bo bow let's listen to
what this [ __ ] piece of trash
from a senator from indiana the
republican senator the gqp the fascist
fascist
white
wrinkly old republican ball sack from
indiana has to say so you would be okay
with the supreme court leaving the
question of interracial marriage to the
states
yes i think that that's something that
uh if you're not wanting the supreme
court to weigh in on issues like that
you're not going to be able to have your
cake and eat it too i think that's
hypocritical
oh you piece of [ __ ] garbage he goes
on to talk about other court decisions
that that
leave states rights to ban contraception
for married people
um he goes on to talk about this that
the supreme court does not have the
right to protect the liberty of the
american people you piece of [ __ ]
trash
you trashy [ __ ] this is what
they want i've been saying this for
[ __ ] weeks and months this whole
their
the the the bounty hunter bill in texas
the [ __ ] don't say gay bill in
florida and then texas trying out
florida florida by by wanting to execute
women who get a medical procedure
missouri making it a [ __ ] felony for
women to leave the state to go get a
medical procedure that could possibly
save their life
everyone's like oh tony you're blown in
out of proportion it's not that bad bull
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is the slow walk to the
fascist state that they want
they want to turn the clock back to
where they can basically make your
interracial marriage
in a state where you live
illegal
that's what they want to do not only do
they not only do they want to make it
illegal that you're gay or say the word
gay not only do they want to make it
illegal that you that you as a woman
have no liberty over your [ __ ] uterus
at all so much so that they'll execute
they're so [ __ ] pro-life they're so
[ __ ] pro-life that they'll [ __ ]
execute you if you go get a medical
procedure that will save your life
that's how [ __ ] pro-life these
[ __ ] are
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
i'm telling you
fascism is on the front doorstep folks
that's what they want this is who they
are they're showing you they're telling
you out loud they're amplifying it
we should not look away
we cannot look away
and we have to protect the rights of
everyone it doesn't matter who it is
rather it's a gay child down in florida
to protect their right to be gay and to
and to
keep that private
if it's the right of of a child in texas
who questions their gender gender gender
identity and receives counseling and
their parents and their other siblings
we protect those liberties we protect
the liberties of people who can and
can get pregnant who who are pregnant
who are receiving eptopic pregnancies in
the state of missouri they are trying to
pass a law that it would make it a
felony
for someone to leave the state to go get
a procedure to save their [ __ ] life
from an etopic pregnancy
and when asked
when asked
the legislator who wrote this bill and
sponsored this bill and the legislator
in the state of missouri when asked if
he knew what an eptopic pregnancy was he
basically said i don't give a [ __ ] what
an eptopic pregnancy is i don't give a
[ __ ]
and you
who thinks that these aren't serious
things
think that they won't come after you
next
first
it was the bounty hunting bill in texas
then it was don't say gay the
transgender bill in tex in texas
now the execution bill the lead the
state be a felon bill in missouri
there's idaho bills
now in the state of indiana there's a
sitting republican united states senator
who says it should be left up to the
bigoted states
rather there should be a legal
interracial marriage
and even
contraception for married people
these are the people who say we want
freedom
we want you to stay out of our lives
my body my choice about the mask and the
vaccine
we don't want mandates
really you don't want mandates you don't
want to mandate that a person who has an
eptopic pregnancy has to die
because they
because they can't get a medical
procedure you're forcing them to carry
that baby to term or die
mandating mandating
you're mandating in tennessee
that a woman who is raped
by her family or any other any other
person is mandated to carry that baby to
term because she can be sued by that
rapist family
you [ __ ]
and they're like oh the left is a bunch
of fascists they're making you wear
masks they're making you get a vaccine
that saves your life
make sure you don't get hospitalized
make you wear a mask when the virus is
spreading around not to cough on people
and get germs and get sick
we need we need freedom from mandates
that don't exist
that way we can create mandates
fascist mandates a fascist state
don't look away i'm telling you you got
to listen to what these [ __ ] are saying
on bannon's trader tv marjorie taylor
green matt gatz that [ __ ] that's running
in washington third joe kent you talk
about a goddamn fascist nazi
why do you think donald trump has has
dumped mo brooks today
donald trump dumped mo brooks is because
mo brooks isn't on the fascist state
train
mo brooks doesn't want a dictator at
this point maybe
don't look away
it's here let's go back to the tweety
tweets and the trinity trends here
okay um
this is a crazy video now wu-tang for
children um
both is this this is from louisiana it's
a it's a tornado look at this
this is crazy
crazy footage
standing on the front porch like that
with that thing that close [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
i'm in a state where we have tornadoes
there's no way i'd be standing on the
boards taking that video
[ __ ] that
i've seen i've seen homes and
communities ripped apart because of that
um uh speaking of um
um ripped apart and disasters
gabe tweets here the only
the only user engagement that true
social gets is on twitter great job at
devin nunes and he claps speaking of
gabe uh we may we may we may have gabe
let's see if he can get his microphone
to work gabe how are you today
i'm good oh your microphone is working
fantastic yeah yeah yeah yeah great
great great great yeah yeah ever
everyone uh on facebook so they know
since we're new to facebook on minus
touch page this is gabe sanchez i want
to introduce you to gabe sanchez he is
our co-host and our executive producer
all the great graphics and everything
that you see yeah when we do an
interview and they get it gets edited um
he may or may not have
done a few edits on the rachel bitkoff
or charlie kirk that video i there
wasn't a lot edited though like just a
few no all i added was the trombone
well and the zooming
yeah yeah of course i was like how could
you not zoom
in on that face you know well it had to
it was perfect
i don't know i can't even do it it's
just like a lot of a lot of
he looks photoshopped right he looks
like a lot of surface area
little face little face you know so so
tell us about um
because because you're going off here
about true social um but you know why
we're on the subject of charlie kirk he
got did he get booted from twitter
yesterday what what's the deal it's just
a it's just like a it's he's just in
twit mode right because he was uh yeah
he
[Music]
i didn't know if i saw a reason i mean
he probably said something but he got
reported and he got at least temporarily
suspended
because it doesn't look like his account
is down let me let me go up let me go
check here
i don't think it's a i don't think his
account is down no i don't i mean i
don't think he's been permanently taken
out but he was at least temporarily
why why is he why is he charlie kirk 11
by the way
because uh charlie kirk 1 through 10 i
don't know it's like
no i think he i think it's gone because
when i type it you can't click on that
on that name look look here look here
yeah like if you were to type in charlie
kirk 11. yeah no i i got the at up here
see that yeah yeah but type it into your
address bar and go directly to it then
you'll see
my address bar yeah you know where you
pipe in the url www.google.com
[Laughter]
listen to this guy listen to this guy
this is a guy who can barely work his
microphone and he's trying to tell me
what to do is i'm serving the internet
give me a break i'm recovering i was i'm
recovering from being sick this past
week i still got what what happened what
happened what it was uh no soda stream
or what's
you know i was worried i thought i had
coveted i really did you take did you
take a test i did i took multiple tests
just to be safe uh
what kind of test did you take did you
take the rapid test and the pcr or what
i took rapid i took rapid tests i took
the actual you know nasal swab tests uh
and all came back negative but there was
a moment last week when i thought i was
i was like oh like because i have not
been sick since before
uh covent
and so then
uh i had a fever and i had a temp
and i was like oh my god like what is
what is uh what is going on i was like
oh my god is this like dope i was like
am i is this is this it is this am i am
i sick now like it's because you you
haven't had gopher like no like
thankfully i have a boy i've had yeah
you know i've had my my shots i got my
booster all that stuff
um and i've stayed pretty pretty safe
like i've gone out but i still wore a
mask and all that stuff but yeah i
thought i had i thought i legitimately
had covet and i you know i'm still kind
of nasally uh well you know i lost my
voice what was that a couple weeks ago
right right and and i i think it was
algae you know i kind of lost my i do
that every once in a while was it
allergies is it is that what you suffer
from no i was just sick like i had a
like was like a virus
yeah like woke up in a you know in a
deep or like woke up it's like full of
sweat kind of like fever or like you
know it wasn't the thing is the other
thing that kind of made me concerned was
like it was a subtle
like
chill in body ache it wasn't major and i
was like oh my god like is this
is this what everyone's been talking
about how it's been like it felt like a
little bit of something but wasn't
totally it you know but it was just i
think it's just the flu from okay good
yeah not allergies not cobid we're glad
you're getting better and glad you're
not yeah you're not you're not uh you're
not over there with the vid yeah yeah
we're happy but even even with my
sickness i still know how to use the
address bar that's good that's good yeah
whatever you found it okay i found i
found charlie kirk's he's still a
now i don't know i don't know
i don't know if he's still able to post
i have no idea uh so he might be in he
might march 21st looks like well uh yeah
looks like march 21st is the last
is this is the same this is the same
thing that uh
that happens with marjorie taylor green
i think they suppress the account so if
you were to type in like empty it is
suppressed
so if you try to if you try to find out
uh
uh
uh how do we know that he's suspended
though did he announce it or some [ __ ]
on another planet somebody posted about
some i think i thought i saw somebody
posting like about the like notification
or the like email he got
yeah he said something about um
i think he said something about
transgender people or something specific
is is what is what people are assuming
probably again that's a big why i mean
here's another here's charlie kirk
uh
well retweeting the post millennial
because the post millennial put his but
his show on their page of course
everyone knows post millennials andy
know that nazi um the the the little rag
that he that he propagates um but there
was something i think i thought someone
said that he was so i mean he's
obviously suspended because he's charlie
kirk he's a [ __ ]
he's a bigot he's right racist so yeah
he might be
he might be in twittmo right now and he
can only read right not actually post
but the same thing before before marger
taylor green got like actually suspended
uh from twitter before
her account was suppressed where like
you would have to actually type in
specifically like mtg
greeny was right was her handle
uh because if you typed in the search
area eric trump is the same way where
they
uh
they do not
show you on search results you have to
specifically type in
so they suppress the account right right
so like the same thing here like if you
tried typing it look for charlie kirk
you couldn't find it you have to type it
in directly same thing with eric trump
and same thing with marjory taylor green
before she got suspended
they're they're so mistreated those
conservatives
with their bigoted views um now turning
points usa they're still tweeting even
32 minutes ago good morning and free
charlie is what they're tweeting this
sounds a lot like uh when trump got
banned and then they were using the
trump war room or whatever it was right
right this is this is charlie kirk's
organization by the way yeah this there
there's there's not much there i mean
this is like if oh there you go i were
defended for
speaking the truth
yep exactly and um oh it's a deleted
tweet he had to delete a tweet that's
why we and we're not seeing it oh yeah
deleted the tweet but they're
tweet out free charlie to support
uh tweet out [ __ ] charlie that would be
uh hashtag [ __ ] charlie um maybe that'll
get them going
you think i should get their attention
here i don't like to give these people
attention but maybe we'll uh
maybe we'll um hashtag [ __ ]
charlie maybe we'll get a joke are you
sure you want to type it that's what
they're going to ask maybe yeah [ __ ]
charlie there we go maybe because it's a
hashtag
[ __ ] charlie and then we'll do we'll do
this
we'll give him the old middle finger
here
let's see dude
we're live tweeting yeah
give him a finger and then give him a
little
oh yeah a kiss yeah yeah you know if i
can find the finger where is it at where
the hell is it at is it not on my my
thing here that's that's really really
oh there you go enough clearly i don't
use the middle finger one um that often
and you want me to give them a kiss i'll
get you a little kiss
yeah blow them like this with the heart
or without the heart with the heart you
got to know oh yeah
yeah there you love you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] charlie [ __ ] charlie everyone
um go
go tweet [ __ ] charlie look at that see
and because you gave it a little kiss
twitter said okay that's not so bad yeah
yeah right right they were like oh the
middle finger and the kiss you're good
to go you're good to go okay so we did
our we did our due diligence here today
uh so uh trendy trends and tweety tweets
your favorite guy mo brooks
as you said
this morning mo brooks no problems yeah
well when you're committing a soft coup
and he won't go along oh did he drop off
the trends he might have
god
i'm curious how quickly he's gonna do a
180 and potentially
try to
collaborate with the jet no i was gonna
say potentially collaborate with the
january 6 committee oh yeah see i've
heard that narrative where he's gonna
like he's gonna like oh yeah now now
that you turned on me see here's the
thing here's the problem that i think uh
that we have with that that scenario or
that
you know that train of thought is that
mo brooks actually helped in the
conspiracy of sedition so it probably
wouldn't be in his best interest at this
point i mean unless you're cooperating i
mean he well i guess there's no criminal
case right now so he doesn't really have
much to uh
but she's used as leverage there are
criminal cases there are criminal cases
when you talk about stuart rhodes right
talk about enrique tario there's
conspiracy to commit sedition and we
know from a rolling stone article now
rather you take it at face value or not
that there were members of congress that
were communicating with some of these
seditious uh conspirators
to get pardons
and and mo brooks is one of the names in
that article and along with paul gozar
marjorie taylor greene madison gothard
and there's several of them you know all
the typical uh right-wing nazis the
swedish's crew right yeah the the
treasonous traders that are the gqp
lindsey graham is trending
at number four um probably because
lindsey graham is a [ __ ] idiot i was
watching some of this before that and i
i caught uh feinstein and cornyn
yeah and
oh my god i swear to god cornyn is one
of the most useless sacks of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
in the senate and all of that please
tell us more please tell us more about
it he starts these lines of questions
like oh
when you call someone or like when you
accuse someone of a crime are they a
criminal
and
kentucky's like uh
what what are you talking about she's
like well if you
uh accuse someone of being or of a crime
are they a criminal and she's like well
i've never done that he goes well no
i'm not saying you did that and she's
like okay so then what are you saying
and he's like well i just want to know
from like this uh
more of a legal standpoint if you call
someone if you say someone uh
or accuse someone of a crime are they
criminal she's like well it all depends
because she sounds like you don't know
then and she's like what and he's like
so it sounds like much like a woman you
can't define it
oh yeah this is this is the blackburn
thing where she asked what basically
blackburn was asking for the definition
of a woman and judge brown jackson's
like i'm not a [ __ ] dictionary she's
actually like i'm not a biologist right
i right well but she's like i'm not a
[ __ ] dictionary i'm not here to give
you a definition of what woman if you
want to know the [ __ ] definition well
go look that [ __ ] up like i'm here i'm
here to i'm the nominee i don't know if
you know this senator blackburn but i'm
the nominee for the supreme court so if
you want to ask relevant questions to
what i would how i would make decisions
maybe maybe you should ask if there is a
court decision where there is a
discussion about the definition of a
woman what a woman is what how what
would be your process of determining
what the definition of a woman is
constitutionally maybe that would be a
[ __ ] question that you asked but
marsha blackburn is a goddamn [ __ ]
and that's why she doesn't ask questions
like that and again judge brown jackson
looks at her like oh god are you really
asking me the definition of what woman
is there's a there's a it's from
yesterday where
you know ted cruz goes on his whole
thing about the anti or the the racist
baby thing right
and there's a moment where she goes
senator
there it's it's it feels like a [ __ ]
eternity
she doesn't want to say like [ __ ] off or
right like she's really she doesn't want
to be like are you [ __ ] serious right
now
like the way that she responded i
thought legitimately when i was watching
and then when i watched a clip back i
thought there was a glitch like it had
just like stuck
on that moment in time but she just goes
no
no i'm not saying that babies are racist
like babies look at their bases like
what kind of question like it's it's
that type of
well it's it's this type of [ __ ]
it's the it's the whole
don't call white people racist because
if you're calling all white people
racist then white baby and it's like no
no if you're offended
if you're offended by someone saying
that white people are racist they're
talking to you right they're talking to
you that and they're talking to you at
any time somebody's like oh well these
mothers like we'll take uh virginia as
an example right oh all these mothers
are speaking out about how their kids
are feeling bad that their teachers you
know make them feel guilty and ashamed
and it's like
show me a kid
who actually comes home goes
mom i feel so bad and i feel embarrassed
and i feel ashamed because of what our
ancestors did show me one kid
who said that if you show me one then i
can then then show me a group of people
because here's the thing i highly doubt
it's the kid coming to the mom
complaining about feeling ashamed
when it's really
the family
the these white suburban mothers who all
of a sudden feel
uh
so victimized because they're like well
i i i don't know anything about my
family history and what they did but
that's them and not me and it's like
okay
one i don't know why you're getting
butthurt no one's literally dragging
your family name through the through the
mud here we're just talking about white
people in general have a very
toxic relationship
in this country especially against
minorities
and babies aren't racist
they're bred that way like they are
raised right nature versus nurture right
and that is what the situation is so if
you've got a problem with how they end
up and how they feel maybe you should
look on your parenting right so so we
both grew up catholic in the catholic
church right and um when when i was
young in the catholic church they didn't
bring up like
uh
the absolute murdering that they did in
south america right when they were like
you're either going to be catholic or
you're going to die um you know that
none of that is taught in the catholic
church now when you go to school i
actually teach world history and part of
world history is that the catholic
church murdered
and tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of people in south america for
the name of religion um and
when you learn that in school i wasn't
like oh my god i'm an awful person i was
like whoa catholic church
they have some horrible history that
they don't teach me at the church like
why don't they say this [ __ ] at the
church like oh that's why yeah that's
why i didn't even know i didn't i didn't
i went to catholic great school i didn't
even learn about that i was learning
about [ __ ] fully alive and how
masturbating was the sin all stuff so so
they were teaching you this stuff this
yeah
style stuff yeah dude it's there's a
there's a series there's a book series
called fully alive anyone out there
who's listening there's a thing called
fully alive and it's what you learn in
catholic grade school and it's like you
know separate the class from the boys to
the girls you're getting separate uh
lessons based on this book and yeah it's
very much ingrained with the religious
side to say like what is you know
they're showing you the anatomy but
they're not really showing you the real
you know they're not they're not really
teaching you is it like pointing to the
kindle like this is where the penis is
supposed to kind of i mean they're like
here's the here's a you know here's the
sexual organ this is how it works but at
the same time it's like
they're suppressing some things and it
wasn't until like freshman year of high
school like obviously my mom is a nurse
and has a medical degree and all right
right and so like i learned these things
and wait a second this is a great school
right this isn't great yeah catholic
grade school
are these the same catholics that the
conservative catholics that are really
upset
really upset
in florida that you cannot have a child
say the word gay yes yes it's the same
mother yeah yeah yeah it's the whole
thing like if you masturbate you're
killing you know kind of thing and i
also want to point out that i've got
this in my dress right now the idea that
white people
uh
feel uncomfortable or feel ashamed or
feel guilty because of crt right right
what the [ __ ] is original sin then
right like you're coming after people to
say you got to feel guilty for this
thing that adam did right right eve did
like that's the whole point right right
they ate the apple
uh you know they they disobeyed god and
now for eternity you are born with
original sin and the only way to get
over original sin is to cleanse yourself
and be baptized so you're telling me
that i'm born guilty for something i did
not do and somebody did
thousands of years ago but i have to
feel bad about it yeah and the only way
to fix it is to just throw some holy
water on myself and
yeah but gabe what you're missing here
what you're missing here is it's not
about that it to white people what white
people don't want to have happen is to
actually learn the truth that way their
white children are empathetic and
sympathetic to other cultures other
other races other genders um any any
identity or culture that they may run
into that isn't there they don't want
them to be sympathetic or empathetic
with that person or understand where
they come from what they want them to do
is they want them to hate that other
culture that other person that other
gender that other race that's what they
want right and because they want that
they have to you know mishmash this crt
[ __ ] which by the way did you see
the gop they they took
um judge brown jackson's identity away
from her and actually put crt the most
racist [ __ ] thing that you bought
yeah like we're not racist right but
right what this is though the initials
crt right well this is the whole thing
like in the white community here's what
happens a lot of times like when you
push back on someone like i'm white i'm
a white dude and i'll push back on
someone's racism they'll say things like
well
i'm not racist but
that's that's the phrase i'm not racist
but i just don't like all black people
or you know that that's
you know that like but okay well that's
kind of racist like that yeah that's the
when you throw in a claw like a butt
claws right in there you know like
you're like with that being said i'm
actually pretty racist right right right
right like that's what you're saying
right at the end of it oh it happens a
lot though it happens a lot oh it
happens a lot in the white community in
their little circle especially when
someone white which everyone out there
who is white and is in the circle and
they're being racist even even just uh
you know a hint of it you know and
you're calling it out you should keep
calling it out that's the whole point
right is that um you know they'll say
things well i'm not you know they'll say
something racist right and someone will
call them out and they're like well i'm
not racist
but and then that's that's their
justification for the racist [ __ ] that
they just said but let me tell you the
stereotype right group of people and
you're like uh that's you just negated
what you just said before that like what
are you what are you doing and like no
i'm not i do i'm not racist i just said
that i just said i'm a racist
if you start anything but that's what
they are racist
don't worry you're not racist then it's
like a it's like a blank title you don't
have if you're not racist or you don't
intend to be racist because it's a lot
of times i i think there's sometimes
people you know what might say something
that that someone else thinks is racist
that their their intention isn't right
um you know a lot of white people want
to get away with well i i wasn't saying
the n word to be racist but right but
there is i was using it to give context
right exactly did you need to give it
context right
but i think but here it bears its own
weight but a lot of times there there
isn't the intention but you are saying
race is [ __ ] right
but there's not the intention but
but that's but that's when they go into
the justification when they realize
oh it is it is right but that's the
learning process that's a learning
process that all white people need to
have in this country is because there is
white privilege speaking of white
privilege speaking right approaches
let's go to the uh back to the tweet
tweets because lindsey graham is
trending i have a couple clips here that
maybe we should we should look at justin
posted here he says yes yes he did
here's lindsey graham once again
storming out of the room
this time he did it again today yeah
he's a little [ __ ] oh my god he's a
little [ __ ] did he grab his diet coke
like yesterday well i don't does he
drink diet coke i don't know i thought i
saw a diet coke i thought it was diet
yesterday when he was like yeah from
afghanistan blah there's a there's a
circus
yeah what what what was why was he
blaming her for the trump's no exit plan
of afghanistan
it's really weird it's really weird like
everyone's like why are you complaining
about detainees being released like
trump released detainees and then trump
made the deal with the detainees to take
over the afghan government right right
why are you blaming her yeah
another person using their time to ask
dumb ass questions like
well i mean i mean you know let's be
frank they want the 20 second clips for
fox news right exactly yeah but the i
mean well here's the thing they want the
clip but then they go on [ __ ] oan and
newsmax and fox news later that night so
it's like or like right after recess
they're like right book me
but for him you know he had questions
that were also like what is your faith
and she was like
because to anyone
there is a there should be obviously a
separation of church and state so if
you're asking someone on a legal side
what your faith is
faith religion should have nothing to do
with the influence of your opinion when
you uh when you decide on a case and so
he's like what's your faith and there's
like a
uh moment and she goes protestant and
then he and then he was like and then
she's like oh i'm you know whatever and
then uh he goes so you're practicing or
you know she's like well i find my faith
helpful but also there's no nothing in
the constitution that says i have to be
you know it's like and then you know
it's a dumb irrelevant question that one
takes up time but also is they're tr
it's again you go through the list of
things that make her disqualified and
there's
little if anything right i would say
she's not qualified if not she or like
also the fact that she would probably be
one of the most qualified judges that
we've had she absolutely right
absolutely is one of the most qualified
nominees and so then you look at them
and they're like well [ __ ] like we're
going through the list of stuff and we
can't find a legitimate thing to
complain about okay we're going uh
racist babies we're going religion we're
gonna go child porn right you had
you had cornyn yesterday who was like
listen uh i don't wanna say
that we should get rid of uh same-sex
marriage
but what i am like he's like i'm not i
don't want to i don't want to judge the
merits like we're on [ __ ] merits now
like that's how we're deciding if people
should like live their lives and get
married within the same sex how many
people do you know who give a [ __ ] who
someone else loves how many people do
you know can you count on your i don't
know anyone i don't know that many
people who give a flying [ __ ] even
people who are really conservative who
are against gay marriage right like
they're like i don't really like it but
who am i to say you were mine to [ __ ]
tell someone else like most people in
this country like leave them the [ __ ]
alone at this point because at the end
of the at the end of the day
they live their life
in their own home right doing their own
thing no one's forcing
not coming to your home and trying to
change your lifestyle they can give two
[ __ ] about you they want to stay as far
away from your bigoted as this is
possible they're busy living their own
life and saying [ __ ] like i i don't have
certain rights or like uh i heard
certain areas don't respect me so i have
to worry about that as opposed to i'm
some old wrinkly white ass man and i
have all the knowledge
wrinkly republican ballsack that's what
we're going to do okay got it wrinkly
republican
and you can also you can also rb yeah
you can also you can also sub in nutsack
wrn
wrinkly republican nutsac likely
republican ball sack say 10 times fast
yeah well you know
all right let's let's listen to a
wrinkly republican nut sack here as in
lizzy lindsey graham let's see let's see
him be a little [ __ ] and storm off the
fact of the matter is that i'm
co-sponsor of your bill the earned act
and i believe that we should be doing
our job here but part of our job we have
failed in responding to the changing
circumstances
that face this crime what has it been 15
or 16 years oh this is from yesterday
she is currently not an outlier in
sentencing 70 of the federal judges face
the same dilemma and wonder why congress
has failed to act and when it will act
this is our fault pardon partially it is
senator to be honest with you it is we
have to upgrade these guidelines and
decide whether we're going to stick with
the supreme court decision that they're
not mandatory
senator feinstein thank you very much um
mr chairman helix he licks his lips when
he's pissed doesn't he isn't this from
yesterday no this is from today this is
today that same okay because almost that
ver that thing verbatim from uh yeah
that's right urban yeah that's why
durbin's so [ __ ] pissed off there's
right he's got to say
durbin illinois just want to say him and
obama great job
you know as senators in the state uh but
for this was almost identical to what
was being brought abusively because they
keep bringing this [ __ ] child well
yeah because they don't they don't have
anything else right they don't have
anything else right
this is what i've been saying is like
this is the difference between
republicans democrats everyone's like oh
there's no difference between the
parties [ __ ] this is a good example
right here in the nominees they had to
ask brett kavanaugh kavanaugh over and
over and over again did you sexually
assault women because he was accused of
sexually they cannot accuse katangi
brown jackson was sexually assaulting
anyone they can't they can't accuse they
can't accuse katanji brown jackson of
hiding her bigotry behind her religious
dogma because she doesn't like like amy
coney barrett does they do these things
so yes you have to ask them these
questions the republicans are [ __ ]
pissed especially lindsey graham because
they don't get to ask the questions that
were asked to brett kavanaugh and amy
coney barrett because
brat judge brown jackson is a decent
[ __ ] human being and isn't one of
those pieces of pile of [ __ ] right it's
not exactly and that's why they're
pissed off because they don't get to ask
those questions this is uh let's see
this and even when they've been
corrected and they've been fact checked
like dick durbin did a good job
yesterday of that where he was like hey
so listen uh josh hawley uh you voted
yes on these people who then decided on
these cases and went less than half of
what the right suggested sentencing was
right they brought up they brought
receipts they all brought it was great
it was great to see like i wish there
was more live fact-checking happening
but i'm glad to see it in here i just
kind of wish there was like uh like
america's got talent or like some sort
of america
uh uh american idol type of buzzer that
just like like as soon as a a a false
statement is made on both sides on both
sides um
is made
uh just simon cowell's there with the
buzzer just like slapping that [ __ ]
maybe maybe we should get because
there's there's a fact checker you like
really uh you got a relationship he's
busy he's busy okay i'm just saying
daniel dale could daniel dale is busy
focusing on margie taylor green clap
videos so he's he's like i've lowered
the air compressor i'm trying i'm trying
to give him some job security here god
damn it yeah i know the only people give
him job security seems to be minus
touching myself god damn it you know it
happens has he has he fact checked your
marsha blackburn photo or your mobrooks
he's probably he's probably still
counting how many times marjorie taylor
boom clap so he might be counting how
many times uh they're like oh well uh
lindsey graham was licking his lips 50
times it'll be like okay how many times
you know right actually 32 and a half it
was 32. how many licks are the center of
that tootsie pop
so here is here's senator lix's lips
again um
let's watch this clip this is this is
before he stormed off i believe so what
happened with janice rogers brown
in 2003
she was an african-american nominee for
the dc district court yeah
uh 54 years old a little bit older than
you but pretty close okay what's that
[ __ ] what is that
sharecroppers a childhood in alabama
under jim crow okay
she was a uh single mother yeah
get to it lady gamer of the
california supreme court what does it
have to do with our jobs celebrating
how far we've come
my democratic colleagues filibustered
her ascension to the d.c circuit court
because it's well known on our side
that we
were very much considering her
to be the first african-american woman
on the supreme court well if you did you
should have brought her up then what why
right what the [ __ ] you have three
nominees yeah they're like we were going
to and it's like don't give me that
[ __ ] if you were going to then you
would have don't say this like well we
were we were planning her we were trying
to groom her into this role no no if you
feel like she's qualified and you feel
that she is a good candidate you would
have put her name in the running the
last three people that you [ __ ]
nominated for the supreme court instead
of two white guys and one hands-made
bigoted woman right well i mean you know
this is this is the old oh you're
against conservatives yeah conservatives
ideas [ __ ] suck right they [ __ ]
suck you know what this sounds like this
sounds like i'm not racist i have a
black friend right i'm not racist
we're not racist because right we had a
black woman that we may
have said
it's like we're not being racist and
disqualifier for her race which we are
the republican party
because if we were then why would we
have wanted to
in the future nominate this woman
uh that we're bringing up right now it's
irrelevant unless you actually brought
forward her name as a candidate you have
to shut the [ __ ] up well here's the
thing
back to the gop little meme that they
did where they crossed out uh kbj and
put crt yeah if it was a white man that
joe biden had nominated and let's say
they're there
well here's the thing
the gop would have never put a picture
of his face
with his initials and crossed out and
put crt no [ __ ] win no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way yeah here is here is
apparently uh lindsey graham who can't
stop interrupting uh judge brown jackson
here's a footage and proof and evidence
of it let's watch this in prison
good
good good
absolutely good i hope you are to do
good allow her to finish please
go to jail for 50 years if you're on the
internet trolling for images of children
and sexual exploitation so you don't
think that's a bad thing i think that's
a horrible what the witness said she
should be allowed to answer this
question once and for all senator
senators
lindsey graham is terrified of uh judge
brown jackson's answer
and that's what that is and the reason
why he's terrified of her answer is
because he needs his 20-second clip for
fox news he needs to show that he he he
fought he fought the good fight
instead of actually what you did was you
had a tantrum on television here's
another uh aaron's post of this clip
this is another clip of him uh whining
about brett kavanaugh which is [ __ ]
fantastic i love i love when lindsay
like this this points i love that
they're actually asking these questions
and lindsey graham is acting like this a
lot of you're like oh it's despicable
but it only shows you how [ __ ]
despicable and how unqualified and how
brett kavanaugh should not be on the
supreme court yeah it just it makes it
glaringly obvious watch this pam i know
i'm out of time and uh listen i you're
always living an incredible life
but here's one thing that won't happen
to you as we wrap this up
here's one thing that won't happen to
you because you're black that's what he
that's what he's saying is this a threat
like what is he about to say well he's
about to he's about because he did this
yesterday he's about to talk about how
brett kavanaugh was mistreated how the
white guy
white people are so mistreated in this
country and they're held to such a
higher standard and because you're black
you're not held to that standard watch
this would you feel
that if i'd had a letter
from somebody accusing you of something
a crime or they can't there is no letter
because she doesn't commit crime what
the [ __ ] don't they understand about
this the reason why there was
allegations against brent kavanaugh
because brett kavanaugh was a despicable
piece of [ __ ] still is still right [ __ ]
right but that's why he was asked those
questions why how did allen they know
this misconduct
for weeks
and i give it to senator durbin
just before this hearing's over
and not allow you to comment on the
accusation how would you feel about
that it doesn't matter i don't have an
xjc senator i'm i'm not sure i don't
understand the context of the question
well let me did you just watch the game
i'm not hearing this so that's perfect
she baited him so [ __ ] well because
she's about to do she knows exactly what
he's talking about absolutely and he's
like
say it out loud say what you're pissing
right right tell tell me tell me racist
white man why you don't like that i'm a
black woman sitting here as the nominee
how are we the same are you familiar
what happened in the kavanaugh hearings
generally senator your time as well well
please mr chairman
uh
so
to be honest submitted in 47 seconds
she filibustered every question ahead
and she has the right to give an answer
but i'm trying to make a point in 20
minutes what's funny is she doesn't have
the right to filibuster because she's a
black woman as the nominee right but the
republicans
the right
yeah i can fill a bus well they know the
senate all the time and racist
they can filibuster on the floor to make
sure that americans don't get their
voting rights [ __ ] right you were here
for kavanaugh if she's confused about
what happened some people on the other
side had an accusation against judge
cavanaugh that during high school
he sexually assaulted somebody
and the rest is history that was known
to the people on the other side and
never revealed during the meetings they
had with judge cavanaugh it was
literally ambushed he was ambushed oh my
god are we going to bring up the uh
reports that came into the fbi that they
didn't go on like are we going to talk
about that like
so ted cruz tried to do this yesterday
as well with this with this nominee
when they brought in the evidence that
we were talking about earlier about the
other judges that these senators had
voted for that had the same if not worse
record of giving a light quote-unquote
sentence to um child predators in
federal court the thing is is like that
judges are
they have guidelines that they have to
follow i mean they can pretty well do
what they want but they can't just like
give someone life for a charge that
doesn't have life like there's there's
there's a certain threshold that they
have to meet um but
and she explains that yesterday in
detail of how that works like she does a
really good job of it because she's
qualified and smart and she she's done
it before right um these [ __ ] idiots
don't understand that even tom tillis
today said he's he's not a lawyer but he
watches law and order or something like
that yeah so anyways so anyways um
they did this yesterday to ted cruz
where
i mean ted cruz did this to durbin said
oh you brought this evidence in at the
last moment this evidence of these of
these judges and their opinions and us
voting for them like just because you
got caught voting for what you're saying
she's doing
doesn't mean that it's a [ __ ] ambush
you voted
you voted for the person just because
you decided not to to to do your
background check on child porn for the
republican white nominees that you're
doing for this black woman because it's
the only thing that you feel like the
only the only thing that you got to
spread around [ __ ] right wing media
about how bad she is because literally
this is the this this and the get mo
thing are the only thing only strands
they have to make her look bad i'm not
even going to play the rest of this
lindsey graham quit clip
um and then of course there's several
clips of him on the news you know last
night which i'm not even going to go to
that let's give credit for this last
clip that i did play from aaron we'll
retweet
and we give credit here you know that
thank you for the tweet aaron okay what
else do we have in the news when lindsey
graham was trending sorry we got down a
rabbit hole with lindsey graham of
course scotus confirmation hashtag
skoda's confirmation is now turning at
number
four as these boneheads um continue to
go on and on and on um they'll uh
they'll continue to trend uh here's the
tillis one um
maybe maybe yep here's the clip let's
watch this real ah it's five minutes
damn they don't have a smaller [ __ ]
clip of this i hope he says this in the
beginning a little bit about
um
they
you think the [ __ ] i can't even take it
this [ __ ] guy i can't even give now
this credit because i guess the fact
that he would go listen i'm not a lawyer
whatever you're about to say shut the
[ __ ] up right don't quote me the quote
the quote that they've been doing
but now
or yeah i'm not an attorney
i watch lawn order the time
no no you don't have to say time to time
yeah i watch law and order that's the
quote that's the thing you know what
this is you know what this is
this is
dunning krueger right it's the people
that think they're the smartest in the
room are actually the dumbest and it's
the same thing here it's like i'm no
medical expert but i read a i read a
thing on breitbart about covet that's
the same type of [ __ ] that i'm
hearing right here i'm not an attorney
but i did my own research
i'm no attorney but i know everything
there is no about constitutional law and
civil rights so
that protest is illegal like no that
it's the same type of [ __ ] that i'm
hearing right there it's like i'm no
expert so then shut the [ __ ] up is where
it should go you shouldn't even you
shouldn't even get that out of your
mouth i'm not this then you should have
no opinion right it's the same thing as
the butt thing that we were talking
about earlier everything after the butt
you're [ __ ] so uh home depot is
trending and it's because many react to
the uh alleged home depot training flyer
shared online from an employee titled
leading practices unpacking privilege
when i first seen this leading practice
un packing privilege i was like
unpacking are they trying to tell them
how to stock privilege in the store it
was really confusing at first when i
seen the the headline but if you go down
and you look at the um and you look at
the uh
here sirius woke black
has
says if this home depot privilege guys
upsets upsets you you're the reason why
it's needed again if it upsets you
they're talking to you
um as a black woman there are four
privileged boxes i can check on this
form
which i have no problem acknowledging
so here is the here's the form here um
and here's the privilege boxes that
she's talking about uh it says if you
don't have to think about it it's a
privilege check your privilege these are
huge boxes with icons next to them right
you know i i don't know what's so hard
to understand it's like are you this
all right that do you ever
i don't well so if you look at this um
unpacking privilege again this is a
picture of this and i guess i guess this
is uh privileged training or something
that they're doing i'm not sure yeah
what homelessness and it gets a name
right unpacking privilege like they're
you know it's a little bit of a pun kind
of right right right home depot and
everything
but also yeah this should not offend
anyone well they're they're pr they
define the word privilege as a special
benefit or advantage that may be earned
or unearned yeah right and then they
define social privilege white privilege
and then what privilege looks like they
give examples of those privilege and
then down at the bottom um they talk
about uh uh racism it's racial prejudice
plus power um and basically your racial
prejudice plus your power over someone
equals racism and they define those
things this looks like a goddamn grade
school worksheet right it is
that's what this is this is what we come
down to we have to
break this down right because words are
hard right and concepts are very
difficult to understand so now we have
to give you a goddamn you gotta know
equation yeah right you gotta get a
worksheet to know what this is
this equals this you know it's like
where does the square block go no not in
the round hole
so i guess a lot of people are pissed
off you know especially white privileged
people are pissed off that the home
depot has to point out their privilege
to them and they're not pointing it out
to people who know that you have the
privilege they're pointing out people
who don't know they're also not calling
and they're not specifically calling
people out to be like hey
you're a racist or you're a big or
anything it's just like hey if you
identify with any of these things you
might have an unfair advantage and
privilege and that you're not aware of
it right right
this is just meant to be educational
this isn't meant to make you feel bad
this isn't making your kid at school
feel bad listen
listen gabe
definitions of words they're out to get
me and we have to change the definition
of words or swipe them from the book all
together because it might make me who is
not privileged for sure feel bad
yeah
the fact that you could just stand up
and say that you know well that's that's
that's what they that's that's what
they're saying right that's what they're
saying when they when they go through
this and and you know i've said this for
a long time because i 100 believe
there's white privilege i've seen it i
know it i have it and the reason why i
try to use my white privilege to smash
other white privilege because i i
believe the only way to that you achieve
not just equality but equity and that's
the key word there is equity is to give
everyone the same privilege which then
they're not privileges anymore right um
but if i can use my white privilege to
smash white privilege let's do that
that's that's how i feel so uh
congratulations i guess to home depot
for trending for this i i don't know i
have to i'm sorry i'm gonna have to make
a sketch about this now i don't even
know this was in existence yeah until
you just brought it up and the fact that
it's like okay kids which one are you
you know like that's
you you play a game show
privilege are you
i've had other game shows which is like
is that a gun was one
uh and also uh jeopardy insurrections uh
edition was another one so yeah i could
definitely bring a game show back or it
could just be a guy who's like
oh god all right let's go over this
again guys uh the word is privilege you
know
i wonder so this this brings up another
topic and maybe you could put this in
the um and i know you only got 60
seconds
but do you remember when lowe's um there
was something about lowe's and and ben
shapiro got really pissed off at lowe's
oh yeah you know this poppy wood yeah i
made a video called lumber boy
where i i was like the adventures of ben
shapiro yes well and if you want to
watch it i could probably find it um but
but uh
i i think i called him little boy lumber
is what i called him
but remember he was all for home depot
at that time
because remember lowe's was the the
radical socialist commie company or some
[ __ ] i don't remember what was happening
did anyone remember why he was he was
going to home depot yeah yeah so the
reason is because because i made a video
about him in home depot trying to talk
about hardwood
and hard wood yeah yeah it was the first
time he had seen it so
yeah i think that's why i think i
actually do that in the end
so the reason he was mad was because of
their um
or not matt he was supporting them
because they had not spoken up about the
uh
uh the georgia law that was that was um
that was currently
uh being presented
i believe that's what it was
oh yeah oh yeah because because home
depot
and and lowe's are both in georgia right
and georgia had not said anything so he
showed up and was like i'm to give my
business a lot or to home depot and i
did that by buying this i'm a proud
owner of this popular this wood but it's
poplar wood i think you might have said
popular wood yeah i think he said and
it's in a plastic bag
which is like whether he was you know
some people were like oh he was trying
to be coy and funny and it's like
whether he was or not or whether he was
trying to or not it came off
desperate and cringy and the joke fell
flat on its face because at the end of
the day
he looks
like a little boy holding this wood
boy lumber little boy lumber here let's
let's let's see if we can
fake ass mackeezmo let's talk ben
shapiro walked inside of a home depot
and pretended he knew what aisle the
[ __ ] lumber was in oh to own them
libtards the non-material buying kind
what the [ __ ] fascists do know that lows
exist right jesus [ __ ] christ of this
macho man [ __ ] everyone knows that
ben shapiro has never handled a piece of
wood in his life
wink don't make it so [ __ ] obvious no
one puts their lumber in a plastic bag
and you hold papa like trump holds the
bible whole list of these manga makismo
[ __ ] to deal with there's
little boy lumber shapiro there's tucker
bow tie carlson and then there's charlie
aminati kirk what the [ __ ] and god's
name makes these maga makismo trump
supporting white males and their arm
karen's like these [ __ ] rubes
[ __ ] them
i don't know i i think little boy lumber
is a good is a good there's a good
nickname for him
now apparently he was mad at home depot
in this he was i thought wasn't home
that he was mad at him
he wouldn't have gone and made a
purchase because he went to the home
depot right he went to the home depot
and did it because i said i said lo in
the video i said he they do know that
lows exist right because i think i
and maybe
well i don't know like here's the thing
i know that he would not have shopped at
because he did a whole video he was like
home depot was in support of something
so he went and supported them or some
[ __ ]
right or rather it was the lack of they
didn't say anything i think it's what
happened he's like they shouldn't get
involved in politics so i'm going to
show my support by shopping for this
piece of wood
right right and you know you know that's
that's funny if that was the case
because i think that's pretty much where
that was that he was in support of home
depot because they weren't going to
participate in the quote-unquote policy
right yeah right
and the funny part of a funny part of
that is is that if home depot were to
participate in politics like this he
would be like oh you're [ __ ] right
because that's what the whole thing with
coke and the mlb moving locations and uh
delta they all had come out and spoken
against this law
about uh what was it the water bill it
was the water bill where they couldn't
give out water right they couldn't pass
it yeah yeah that was yeah it was one of
them it was one of the things that was
attached to this like right right you
can't do these things and they were like
hey that's not cool after a bunch of
people had spoken up and said hey if you
want our business you should speak up
and they're like okay we probably should
speak up and all these businesses did
that and then there was like you know
building their cancel culture wall of
companies because they're like oh
we don't we don't want that we don't
want that and so then they're like
you've been canceled you've been
cancelled like sonic and coke and uh and
not home depot but uh
but also well the mlb they hated the
yeah right they were like mlb and it was
just like okay we're just gonna leave
because we don't support this and it was
a full list like the list goes on of
different companies and different
musical artists that were also out there
no this is coming all back to me and the
reason why is because
the entire trump apparatus is like [ __ ]
coca-cola they can go stuff it and then
as donald trump is still keep that code
right
diet coke button
but
cool right right coke not diet cool two
different things two different companies
not the same thing yeah yeah not the
same not the same thing okay let's let's
go back to the trinity joint maybe we
can find something here um that will uh
interest gaben into a video we need we
need more videos um yeah so let's see
we've got of course the contangi brown
jackson oh aca is here to stay um did
you hear today is the 12th birthday i
saw this post okay this one here yeah
yeah
laura says i'm a stage four cancer
survivor and the affordable care act
saved my life now we must fight to
expand it pca is here to stay that's
fantastic
uh yeah i think i think it's 12 years
old right am i getting that right is it
12 years uh yeah 2010. uh here here the
speaker of the house nancy pelosi i hate
how she tweets by the way she says like
a thousand a thousand words and ten ten
will do
mayo mayo um needs to give nancy some um
some some tips on tweeting because mayo
can like get as few letters as possible
uh nancy pelosi the speaker house says
12 years ago today democrats created a
life-saving affordable care act
republicans keep on trying to kill it
also she doesn't have to send it you
know we get it we know who it's from
well even despite the deadly covet ban
pandemic but democrats won't stop
fighting to stop the sabotage protect
our care and expand coverage
signed in the p i think she does that
because sometimes her team tweets for
those are the good tweets like that yeah
yeah you're like well this is a bad one
i guess you know i guess this is when
like when you deal with customer service
and there's like different people who
might be answering the question so they
add like a signature to it or like
initials
but this is your team pelosi they speak
their voice is your voice right right
you wouldn't approve them saying
something so what they say is really
like what you're saying you know
well it is
it just
she needs to learn how to tweet sorry
sorry a speaker of the house i did you
know there's a lot of things that i like
about you um the one thing i like about
her she's the gqp kryptonite like she's
full-on yeah they melt when she comes
around which i love um but
i just hate how she tweets okay uh let's
see is there any other
[Music]
i really know well midas says something
here uh it's the 12-year anniversary the
affordable care act and republicans are
still to this day threatening to take
you take away your health care right
reply to aca here's a to tell the gop to
keep their hands off
they like their hands on a lot of things
don't they they do without consent right
well and also
um they love to shout in the wrist have
you noticed that i said this earlier but
josh ollie
he has obsession with porn but it's
weird because like most people don't
just like
blurt out porn when it's not yeah yeah
yeah yeah like he's like in a restaurant
being like sir would you like more water
chop porn child porn like what what
what's not just you know i i actually i
actually came across a video how did you
yeah uh do you have the link to that
video maybe we could show
uh i i don't i don't
if you go to my profile oh oh okay so i
think i i can do some work here yeah i
just clicked click the link and to go to
the thing you know i think i i think i
actually may have retweeted a video that
you're talking about possibly yeah let's
see it's on mine here somewhere um well
here's a picture of mo brooks and his
bulletproof vest
yeah and then um oh here's marge the
marjorie taylor train well [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] well one in the same i guess maybe
you should do a video about that a
bird's nest and marshall blackburn's
hair yeah uh let's see um no just go to
i think it should be pinned
on my profile oh okay you got it you got
a pen on yours you found it and you
penned it oh here yeah i gotta let
people know what i found okay okay so so
describe this video because this is this
may be evidence right
right yeah so i don't know daniel dale's
out there listening but this might be
i i came across this uh video on the
internet and uh it's actually josh
hawley senator of missouri josh hawley
calling into tech support to help with
this computer turns out he's got some
issues going on and he needs a little
assistance okay i i like that you said
senator
of missouri not from because he's not
yeah yeah he's not from yeah he doesn't
live there so let's listen to uh josh
holly the senator who represents
missouri um talked to tech support here
about maybe a problem he's having with
his laptop thanks for calling tech
support who am i speaking with josh
hawley can you repeat that
josh holden still can't hear you josh
hawley thank you mr holly what seems to
be the issue my work computer is really
slow i can definitely help you with that
i've tried everything can you just log
in and fix it i'm sending a link to the
email that we have on file can you click
that done look man you gotta promise me
no one's gonna find out about this not
to worry mr holly i've got you guys
what the [ __ ] what's wrong what kind of
disgusting porn is this that wasn't me
oh my god your computer it's
it's full of porn my computer was hacked
by who uh antipa huh ukraine what it's
under biden's laptop mr holly this
computer has no signs of malware and
also it's registered under your name
just kidding it was for research wait
wait so which is it were you looking at
porn or were you not looking at porn
it's part of my job what job i'm a u.s
senator does being a u.s senator also
include googling best buffet
[Laughter]
the christian podcast i do with my wife
aaron thanks for calling he does a
podcast with his wife
and it's a christian podcast that's a
real thing that's not made up
his wife is also a judge
do what
yeah google it look it up
is she a judge in missouri
i think she's a she's a supreme court
judge
is she like not the supreme court but uh
right right but what state
what states oh i don't know missouri
because
but that one means that that means to
have to live in missouri right right
right
are you sure are you sure look it up
right now i can't use my mouse my mouse
is broken
are you serious yeah it's it's literally
it's frozen it can't i can't use it
right now is it because you gotta charge
it every once in a while i know it's one
of those dumb [ __ ] charts but you
have to charge at the bottom i can't
like plug it in the front you know so so
why so why don't you plug it in while
we're because i don't have the cable
next to me
so you're you're wait a second you're
sitting here suffering because your
mouse is not working i can't wait
like i could tell there was something
wrong with you like i thought you were
sick i was i was talking about sick
earlier yeah yeah look it looked like
i'm trying to use my track pad but then
the batteries that go in and are dead so
i'm i'm so so wait a second wait a
second so just so everyone i'm like i'm
stuck on an island just so everyone
understands out there just so everyone
understands
gabe gabe's life is tied to um a design
on the computer and stuff on the
computer so right now we actually have
him like in a locked cage almost right
here live on air like he can't do
anything um
even if he wanted to tell me something
he couldn't even click
never mind han found the cable
[Laughter]
she see this is all you need is a little
encouragement and a little push to
motivate yeah yeah i'll plug it i'll
plug it in now okay and
we should be good to go in a moment but
i can't look up i can't look up the
thing i'll send it to you in a moment
okay okay so so that's why you couldn't
send me the link i was like no you can
send a link you can't i can't i can't
send the link okay i got you that's why
that's why you kept making me do all
these things yeah yeah yeah i see
mo brooks is trending again again
at number six again okay um
you know i want to make fun of this guy
a little more and i don't think i don't
think we made fun of him enough today
um
it looks like
did you read the statement from uh the
cheeto desk yeah it was a it was word
garble right
i mean i mean how did he do writing it
seeing that you sneaked down to
mar-a-lago and right now
it was it was been not bad i'd give it
like an eight out of ten an eight out of
ten on the trump scale for yeah
yeah like you think he wrote it
i think he wrote it this is it right
because you want to know why
uh
because one the types of sentences and
the amount of quotes that he has in
there
and
the random
uh
capitalization like
so
is that how you like if you're like when
you're writing these because sometimes
gabe sneaks into mar-a-lago and does
trump's statements for him
daniel dale they're real yeah they're
real i'm their computer
but but is that how you kind of get
inside the brain is the quote yeah so
the way that i do it is i
i
i've watched and read too many
statements from trump where i know his
style to the extent where he'll like he
throws uh
country
uh election fraud he capitalized he
keeps capitalizing
right like he he capitalizes random
words he also puts words in all caps
when he's like really trying to
emphasize or he puts them in quotes he
thinks he's still tweeting though right
like don't you yeah yeah yeah because i
do that in tweets character limit that's
what it has no character but i mean like
sometimes when i'm tweeting right like i
want something to stand out so i'll like
capitalize it or something like that i
mean you know it's the look of it
sometimes so he's still trying to do the
look of his
of his tweets right yeah yeah and so
very much uh
very yeah it's it's one of these things
where he'll like have run-on sentences
he'll have really short sentences he'll
have quotes a lot of the time he'll
capitalize random words and he'll do
words in all caps to really emphasize
great so i'm glad we had the master
class on how to do a trump but he says
when i endorsed mo brooks
he took a 44 point lead
and was unstoppable
so he's trying to say here that there's
no way mo brooks could lose because he
endorsed him
he then hired a new can page staff who
brilliantly quote unquote i don't know i
don't understand the quote there like i
guess he's saying it wasn't brilliant is
he being sarcastic convinced him to
quote unquote stop talking about the
2020 election right
uh he listened to them then according to
the polls moe's 44-point lead totally
evaporated
based on his 20 there's the quotes again
there's a weird ass question
a 2020 statement made at our massive
rally in coleman alabama um which which
rally in coleman alabama was this
because that was the one you remember i
i know which one he's talking about
because i don't know if there were many
coleman alabama this was the one left oh
yes yes yes yes it was last it was last
year there was a ton of rain it was a
trump rally it was right before the
ivermectin stuff started in
yes i was right about that yeah it was
uh
when the country figured out these
people were eating horse paste right
right because i was i was
i was traveling and i saw it happening
and i was like oh and i i made the video
of all right reposted the video of them
at the trump rally which is a bunch of
sheep
but yeah uh
that's
so so that's that's the i'm not going to
read the rest of the statement but right
the gist of the matter is is that mo
brooks because he won't acknowledge
at this point
almost a year and a half after the
election that the election is what the
election is you're not going to change
because he's not saying that it was it
wasn't stolen what what mo brooks i
guess is saying is that
he's saying that
we can't go back and change it like you
can't that's the thing that's already
happened that's already certified
you can't go and change that election
the only thing you change like the next
one which
if for all maro brooks credit he's right
like you can't go change that election
the only thing you can change is the the
next one i mean the only one donald
trump donald trump is the guy is the guy
in high school who was
you know he played sports i don't want
to say he was the quarterback because
that gives too much credit but you know
one of those guys who definitely peaked
and is living is still living in the
good old days right he's having the
buddies around having a beer you guys
remember when i threw that 40-yard pass
and we scored that touchdown and got us
to state you know that's the type of
mentality that that uh that trump brings
in all of these statements where he
keeps bringing up
election fraud where he's like oh man we
totally would have won the championship
if we had if that dumb ref wouldn't have
called it offside right right like
that's but you didn't right but you
didn't sorry you didn't get the right
right uh
no no i was going to answer your
question about aaron uh aaron hawley
sorry i mean yeah yeah not a judge not a
judge i thought i read someone earlier
she was a judge but
she had clerked for uh
justice roberts she's a uh she is a
lawyer so the both of them are lawyers
i'm assuming they both met at yale
i wonder what her l stat is our llc lsat
yeah yeah i wonder what else i mean
so i'm going to say 400. i i want to
know their ale sets now right now i want
to know how they did so yeah she's a
lawyer uh she
uh the federal society she's a
contributor to the federal society
yeah and she's also uh she previously
served as an associate professor at the
of law at the university of missouri
uh where she taught constitutional
litigation federal income tax task
policy and agriculture law
uh i don't know
what she is up to now
but according this she also worked for
the department of justice
uh i can tell you she's not she's not
getting uh really good um kissing from
josh ollie she's not getting that for
sure we gotta prove that uh
the sphero agnes ghost here
um so it's breaking now this is this is
from today uh 1205. so this is um this
is just about a half hour 40 minutes ago
congressman bro brooks says in new
statement donald trump asked me to
rescind
the 2020 elections immediately remove
joe biden from the white house
immediately put trump back in the white
house and hold a new special election
for presidency what the [ __ ] does that
mean
donald trump asked me
what does that mean
does does
does mo brooks think he has the power or
does donald trump think
that mo brooks has the power because
that's that's like you know the old uh
what emphasis you put on it like right
donald trump asked me
to rescind yeah donald trump asked me
donald trump asked me
i mean you know it's like donald trump
asked me to find 11 780 votes right
right like that's what but yeah this
statement here is
what i love about this is he was like
all right uh just wipe out the 2010
election say it never happened
take out joe biden yeah put trump back
in and then have the election
all over again
right like you would think that if he
was like okay take him out and put me in
and that's it
right but the fact that he was but he's
like oh yeah i'm a dem i'm for this is
democracy take him out put me in and
have the election again let's do a
mulligan guys let's do a mulligan listen
i'm not against some of this stuff in
this statement number one i i i
immediately married joe biden and put uh
trump back in the white house i'm
against that part
but here's the thing
hold a new special election for
presidency this is only another
opportunity for donald trump to lose
badly like yeah like i understand the
country would be like no tony we really
don't but if you look at what happened
in arizona when they kept the recounting
and they kept recounting and every
[ __ ] time joe biden would get more
votes yeah there's something deep down
dark inside me that's like do it
do it
have a special election do it again
let's let this [ __ ] lose again i
don't know something something inside of
me you know it might be
evil but and then it's there yeah i'll
have to admit it so okay um so
apparently um mo brooks is pushing back
on i don't know if that's pushing back i
i don't know like
donald trump pushing back or if it's
rather it's him saying
this is like he's like okay you're gonna
throw me under the bus oh i'm gonna
throw you under the bus [ __ ] and
then he goes this is what trump asked me
to do and then he's like he asked me to
take him out put him in and hold an
election like that's oh so you think
this might be like well i'm rubber
you're glue what i said right i think
this is an attempt this is definitely uh
you know
you know midas uh midas lisa says it's a
lover's bat for sure hundred percent it
is a lover's spec
these two are going at it and he's
asking
he's asking a a us senator to in either
a soul
kind of way or in a in a uh
in a group coup kind of way i'm not sure
but
i think
by him
asking or like by him throwing him under
the bus and being like oh [ __ ] mo brooks
and uh [ __ ] this endorsement mo brooks
is like okay you want to play like that
all right hey listen everybody did you
know that trump asked me to do like i
think that's what like we're bringing
out some dirty laundry right now that's
what's happening
and if they want to do more of that hey
that's the wedges that we need yeah um
your favorite here ron says the guy who
was so proud of his trump endorsement he
made it part of his name uh he started
calling himself magamo brooks
he put it in his twitter handle um and
he says everything trump touches dies i
think ron stole that from somebody i
don't know maybe
maybe he teach lifted that from somebody
i mean ron would never do that um
i i will i will say though i don't say
everything trump touches dies i say
everything trump touches turns to liquid
[ __ ] yeah not as good of a of a hashtag
but everything changes running runny
runny running right but here's mo brooks
he does it does i mean this is a
screenshot i don't know
if mo brooks still yeah fearless fighter
but i wore a bulletproof vest on january
6. right well that's what it means he's
fearlessly
wore a bullet proof vest so that way
he wouldn't get a stray bullet he really
only has 29 000 followers
is that real no wait they just can't be
right yeah that's gonna be right let's
let's let's go find out let's go find
out
mo
brooks
let's go find out
where are you mo
where are you mo
mo brooks it still says
oh he took it off changed it here's the
thing it was
he did that real real yes and it is 27.9
but he changed that recently because
when i look on google and i look at it
it still
counts
president trump
wow
oh wow
so it is a love respect lisa you're spot
on look at that you're spot on
yeah 32 minutes ago he made a statement
it's disappointing that just like it oh
yeah
where's this at give me this link send
it to me send it to me it's right there
scroll down
this one here right there right there
look at this okay it's a little bit long
but it's not too long let's uh i gotta
copy and put it in the window here hang
on
now that i since i've got a mouse yeah
well i got a mouse too oh well yeah i
mean it's working disappointing that
just like in 2017 president trump lets
mitch mcconnell manipulate him again no
i don't want to chat with you yeah
[Music]
mitch mcconnell manipulated him again
so this is dude this is a shot across
the [ __ ] bound this first [ __ ]
sentence i don't know if you people know
this or not but holy [ __ ]
basically what mo brooks is telling
donald trump here is you are mitch
mcconnell's little [ __ ] your mitch's
[ __ ] is what and and everyone knows
that donald trump and michelle kind of
[ __ ] hate each other yeah they
[ __ ] hate each other um that's what
moe brooks is saying here i don't even
know if i need to read any more of this
this is [ __ ] this is a real lover's
pet this is going to be great because
you know the other thing that i think
this is gonna do because this is for the
senate race in alabama right this isn't
like the congress that the congressional
seat of mo brooks right this is the
senate seat in alabama right that
they're they're now firing shots to each
other there is going to be a huge wedge
drawn in the alabama primary now on the
republican side which is opportunity for
democratic voters to draw wedges in the
general election
this is fantastic this is the work that
we need in this country because i've
heard this a lot from people i know
they're like
oh i'm really terrified if if these
trumpers become the nominees i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i've heard this about
eric greitens you heard the news about
eric greitens uh recently right where
his ex-wife has come out and said yes
he's he's committed domestic abuse oh
he's he's he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
yeah now everyone knows that eric
greitens was the the governor of
missouri he was the disgrace governor
because he had to resign and the reason
why is because the truth came out that
he duct taped his hairdresser uh to a
treadmill in his basement yeah he got
her naked
this is this is this is real he got her
naked he invited his hairdresser to his
house he they went to the basement he
got her naked he duct taped her to the
treadmill and took pictures of her and
proceeded to do sexual acts with her and
then threatened to
expose the pictures as she would say you
know expose him now this is real this is
[ __ ] real i'm not making this [ __ ] no
i don't i i this was the former governor
eric greitens this is the guy who's the
front runner in the republican primary
for the senate seat in missouri that's
opened by so you're telling me it's
between him and mo brooks
well not no
yeah i mean like for them as the
republican uh are there other no no this
this is two different states that's the
beauty of this oh oh sorry there's
alright one is in missouri okay one is
in alabama how is that even how is that
better though
it is better it is better let me tell
you let me tell you politically how this
is better yeah because it it sounds
gross and it is
it is really [ __ ] well let's let's
let's talk this out it is really [ __ ]
gross
right but here's the politics of it and
here's the messaging of it here's the
most important thing
uh eric greitens went on steve bannon's
trader tv we showed this clip yesterday
uh of eric greitens saying it's mitch
mcconnell's fault you see that you see
the pattern here it's mitch mcconnell's
fault that this news came out
um and it really is the republicans that
are trying to do a hit job on eric
greitens here in the state of missouri
because i believe the republican party
believes that if eric greitens becomes
the nominee
over vicki hartzler which josh hawley
has endorsed vicki hartzler and that's a
whole another story why holly and
greitens don't get along
because josh hawley was the attorney
general when greitens was the governor
this is a whole [ __ ] drama out here
yeah this is in missouri
yeah now um what happened in the state
of missouri is when this story broke
that eric greitens duct taped his hairdr
his naked hairdresser to a treadmill
and possibly sexually assaulted her when
this story broke
the republicans pounced on it
republicans not democrats yeah
republicans in the legislator the reason
why is because the republicans and
legislator couldn't stand eric greitens
they didn't want eric greitens to win
they didn't want him to win um they
would have much rather had
i believe it was peter kinder was the
democrat who used to be a republican
they would have much rather had a
conservative democrat like like jay
nixon as the governor of missouri
but eric greitens won
that then they didn't like that so
um what they wanted to do was take this
story and do an investigation because
there was also an investigation a
criminal investigation
into his uh veterans charity where he
possibly not only stole donations but
stole the list
he stole the list and used it in his
campaign which is illegal yeah you can't
even wait how is this guy not be charged
with a crime well so that's a good story
the story goes that um number one the
prosecutors kind of messed up some
things about prosecuting him but
but here's the thing
is that he was the governor of the state
of missouri and he was not going to
resign uh the republicans asked in their
sign uh
current members of the party former
members of the party like dan dan uh
senator danforth asked him to resign and
he wouldn't do it um i actually know
some people personally who were um they
weren't didn't work for eric greitens
they worked at the in the administrative
office when he was governor
he is not
he's not all there he's got some issues
um clearly
but he was not going to resign and
basically what the story is is that he
was given a deal you resigned as
governor
will
will get rid of you know basically to
get him out of the the seat of power in
the state of missouri
um you know that's what that's a deal
they made but this guy
this same guy
when he be when he stopped being the
governor of the state of missouri he
went back to the military because of
mike pence mike pence loves this guy
mike pence loves this guy and the reason
why is because mark short and eric
greitens are best buddies you know mark
short is right is
pence's chief of staff right mike pence
and eric greitens are best pals right
and of course eric greitens is a [ __ ]
trump bumper um 100
he's on steve bannon's trader tv he's on
there all the time yeah um
but here's the thing he is the front
runner for the senate seat in missouri
in that primary
even vicki hartzler who is a
congresswoman in the state of missouri
who she's a wackadoo too who josh hawley
the current center is endorsing and that
may tell you something about josh hawley
in the state of brazil
but this guy duct taped his hairdresser
his naked hairdresser to a treadmill in
his basement
and performed sex and took pictures of
her number one uh some say for blackmail
that's the case was the case uh was this
like a civil like a trial against her
versus him or was this a trial against
just like the state
right so the state legislator looked
into these allegations um and it was
republican members who chaired this this
investigative body um i actually i'm
honestly surprised that they actually
went for him yeah well i mean well
but it sounds like the only reason they
did is because they didn't like him to
begin with well the other thing too is
it's a really bad image to have the guy
who duct taped his naked hairdresser
right well i mean yeah but you got to
remember this is this is well before
they got to the point to where they were
okay with matt gatz being a sex
trafficker
we've worked to this point i mean mike
braun is now against interracial
marriage i mean we've worked back to
these positions right yeah i mean this
is a slow rolling fascism yeah right um
and and and disgusting vile uh support
of these fascists
so that so that's the great story about
eric greitens but here's the thing
here's the point i was trying to make
about uh mo brooks
and the eric greitens is eric greitens
is blaming
hit the story recently of his ex-wife
making allegations against him um on an
affidavit in court against mitch
mcconnell and here we have mo brooks who
is now anti-trump right now him and
trump are at it
he's saying that donald trump is mitch
mcconnell's [ __ ] it really does seem
like all roads lead to moscow mitch you
know we always say all roads allude to
putin but maybe
there's a yellow there's a bit of a
gatekeeper there you know to let them
through
absolutely and what i am trying to make
a point of here on messaging if anybody
out there wants to know is that the
perfect wedge to draw between these
[ __ ] idiots out there in these
primaries is mitch mcconnell that is the
perfect wedge to draw in between these
make your decision
make your decision
republicans are you gonna be mitch's
[ __ ]
are you not gonna be mitch's [ __ ] and i
think that is a good wedge that we could
draw between these republicans and i am
so happy so happy that mo brooks pointed
that out so clearly and made it such a
great weapon for democrats to use in
these primaries because that's what we
have to do we have to do the messaging
where they draw wedges in between these
republicans so they fight each other
that's the important thing you know um
we're gonna have bonehead of the week we
got a ton of them to choose from oh boy
this was quite the week do you think do
you think we should do the poll today or
should we wait till tomorrow
i think we should wait till tomorrow i
think there's going to be some bonus i'm
really bad i mean we know we i mean if
there's anyone
certain people have made themselves
known as of yesterday
you know i think our top contenders are
oh absolutely but who knows the regulars
yeah yeah the regulars though we did
have a new one obviously yesterday but
i will say there could be another one
that comes out tonight or tomorrow
morning you know i'm still prepping uh
oh you're gonna be maybe my bone no no i
was gonna say my bonehead madness okay
okay yeah yeah yeah not to be confused
not to be confused
with with march madness right which we
cannot say we cannot say march madness
because cbs will come after me for
saying such madness but i'm getting that
bonehead madness that's the way i'm
right now i'm not conor mcgregor
right we we have to we we want to call
it bone it is bone admitted it is
bone-headed it's just not to be confused
with march madness right exactly yeah
yeah good so i just want to make sure we
point at it so so we'll get we'll get
bonehead of the week pull up so go
follow us at tonymichaelspod on twitter
that's where the bonehead of the week
poll will be hopefully it'll be out
tomorrow or something maybe before we
come on the air so we can show it so you
guys can go vote it just depends on how
many boneheads we collect up because
there's a lot to choose from i think and
there's gonna be it's stiff competition
out there don't make it on this day
they're really trying this week i know
it's crazy and subscribe to the youtube
channel that way you can watch uh
bonehead of the week if you missed it
tomorrow it's in the second hour or
friday excuse me friday we'll do bone of
the week it's in the second hour again
we're here every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch and now on the midas touch
facebook page all the facebook minus
touch facebook fans out there thanks for
joining us and thanks for joining us
today gabe i'm glad your mouse is
working yeah that way you can get some
work done over there yeah it's all over
the screen i'm using it yeah ah that's
good that's good
all right everyone have a good day see
you tomorrow noon eastern 11th centurio
right here on the interwebs until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that perfectly clear we hope you
enjoyed the show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media at the tony michaels and until
next time raise a fist and repeat after
me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking